focus japan mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte die
reise bald wied globetrotters punkt ch
[Musik]
tokio was für ne stoppt erst gar nicht
zum flugzeug stehe und jetzt aus manchem
uncharmante
ich bin so patrick roth ist von der
party fernsehmoderator ziehen
fit bin ich als fotojournalist of the
gods erwartung 142 opfern
welches buch mit bildern und texten das
land mache ich will wissen wer die
manche haben treten
ich bin froh aber esther dennis gehen
sie mit mir der den sv bierbaum sofort
im schweizer rundfunk
aufgewachsen der schweiz er redet über
japanisch und hat lancia kontrakt darum
ist für mich immer sprach seine kultur
übersetzer sie abbauen zeit nicht
einfach so dahin
ist man nur die verhaltensregeln im
aster schlürfe finden wir ja zum
beispiel ohne und ständig nur so
entfaltet sich der volle geschmack vom
ich kann mir vorstellen dass die
reitsport wird ich freue mich auf das
abenteuer
[Musik]
ihr seid ja japan sie kann insel
das stimmt nicht ganz japan besteht aus
obersaxen 800 dienst sie liegen im
pazifischen ozean
die nächste nachbar russland china
nordkorea südkorea und taiwan
[Musik]
2 millionen und 2 5 millionen sind im
großraum tokio
dennis hat man im voller fernsehern
japanische fernsehen
tracht lustig sehr lustig sogar und zu
minute brach sich als jungfräuliche haut
schweizerin halb japanerin ihre namen
christina satow parker kristin ist japan
ein großes da sie schon sogenannte tv
personal wurde frieden stollen im
fernsehen startet als moderatorin vor
spielschluss auf tochter -strukturen
politkommentatoren diese spannende
personen parker kristin mit sagt selbst
er aufgewachsen ist of japan heimatland
vor dem vater allein ohne eltern ganz
große glück
sie darf er kann als lehrer das ist die
zahl verständlich werden terminkalender
petra fischer parks tokio also wird
sprach mit ihrer zürich forscht möglich
liegt im park sind verlässlich
barockzeit dass ich mir die ersten
kirschblüten einfach mit
und 4
nein ich geboren
[Gelächter]
ich bin auf ihre mitmenschen baldiges
ende kontrolliert vor mit druck haltend
und jetzt hab ich mir sie gerade fassen
und wirklich zurückhaltend sind
wo ist der bahnhof dahinter ordnete auch
mit dem fotografieren und fotografiert
wartet das thema
okay okay und machen was man will
in rahmen mit nudeln wie viel das ich
nur träumen
das hat alles doof aber er will
[Musik]
das war einmal
einmal war und einmal noch ein anderer
aspekt dass ich dank immer alles
aber es kommen ja genau
[Musik]
und schon bringt gesichtslosen halle wo
man exit gast wo sich abschotten job
ziemlich speziell geld macht sie auch
bauen überhaupt das mag ich habe nicht
gehört dass stimmt das team
vegas bietet
und jetzt also bin ich nicht noch
zum einen sind typisch erfahren
das war okay
und das heißt hanna okay
[Musik]
mit
danke
[Musik]
am abend will mit der tokioter nacht
aber zeigen bevor es in den job auch
digital designer der live show
produzenten hat derzeit man studiert
unterzieht landtag schaffen
er weiß wie man sich dieser stadt bewegt
[Musik]
wird japans großes kelheim einfach nicht
macht zum beispiel statt angst vor
gesichtsverlust hat also durchaus ihre
vorteile
call option also wo am rand von buck zu
lied golden gate die prostituierte
viertel prostitution ist an die 50er
jahre verboten modells sind hippe bars
ein paar hundert sie sind richtig
verschachtelte meistens mit großen stube
hier gefällt es ist klein die drinks
stammgäste haben ihre eigene flasche
wenn ich hier gast wäre dann hätte ich
meine eigene flasche würde jede nacht
hierher kommen
nicht jede nacht vielleicht einmal pro
woche zwei mal
ich habe heute gelernt dass ich es so
betonen muss
das ist nicht nur eine bahre
ich habe zwei jobs die ich verkaufe
secondhand kleider und arbeite hier
verkaufs kleider die kleider kauft in
den usa bringe sie hierher und verkaufe
sie online
dreister so viel ja ich besuche meine
verkäufer jedes jahr das leben in tokio
steuern seien sehr teuer
in den usa kostet dieses shirt ein bis
zwei dollar in japan fünf bis
sechstausend yen 50 franken
50 dollar ducasse 42 dollar und
verkaufte 5000 das ist ein geheimnis
du bist ein guter verkäufer ist mir
sympathisch
ich würde eine serie fotografieren am
liebsten daheim dann würde ich nämlich
eine box apple tv oder eine offene achte
heimat nach die zuhörer er seit jahren
tennis ist überrascht dass man sie ab
und zu sehe ich eine melodie
sie gibt auch eine ungewöhnlich sei
normalerweise findet sozialarbeit
überhaupt für die eigenen vier wände
statt
guten tag wird das dich wiederzusehen
ein paar monate wieder daheim ein
bisschen älter und das ist 1000 erlauben
großartig das ist das was du online
verkauft nachts in einem webshop
verkaufen und alles ist aus zweiter hand
[Musik]
darum hat der jugo wie viele japaner
zwei jobs das ist dran aber nur viel
stress fliehen wollen nur als
büroangestellter geschafft hat als
sogenannte salary man manchmal konnte
ich nachts nicht nach hause ich arbeite
in der firma und schlief in der wirklich
am schreibtisch auf dem schreibtisch so
echt und am morgen auch ein
weiterarbeiten
ja oft wie lange macht es so ganz
vermutlich acht jahre acht jahre etwa
acht jahren jetzt hat defizit und mehr
für die heute aber es gibt sachen
selbstständige nicht möglich sind
ein eigentlich onyx läufe zum beispiel
ohne feste komme dass die abda mit dem
webshop ein großer traum
wie findest du weißt du was wo liegt ja
ich erinnere mich du hast du aus ein
system ohne ein system zu haben ein
system nein kann ich dir helfen
ja ich kann einpacken jetzt das shirt
ich muss die adresse schreiben kann ich
probieren gelassen zu schreiben
ja auf japanisch ich kann versuchen sind
das chinesisch oder japanisch zeichen
war dass er sein mix japanische zeichnen
aber ursprünglich aus china sehr gut
nein du machst das gut ich glaube der
name reicht jetzt es mir zu viele
persönliche zeichen kannst du die
adresse schreiben
[Gelächter]
ein kunde des am 18
langsam ist so wird das ich frage ob ich
ein paar fotos kannte machen ernst mit
richtig und englischen vereine mann
ich wünsche dir viel glück mit deinem
job und in der bar
die roma wurde geboren gesellschaft mit
viele liebe hat ihn dennis hat tokio als
grosses beziehungsnetz er will mit der
freund vorstellen der siege sehr fotogen
vorwoche nämlich oder mister japan war
heißt mit vollem namen und ist seit 20
jahren
er ist der sohn von der fis handlung
thront mit dem auto und fahrer stunde
hauptzentrum
richtig zufrieden mit dem
landesdurchschnitt er würde gerne ganz
vorne
er hat zwei jobs herrschaften promo
stand vom autohandel und im lager vor
seinem vater er verkaufte palm eine
woche vor seinem vater übernimmt
[Musik]
ich bin patrick ich bin fotograf
christoph der flotte vom jüdischen vater
ist das paradies für fischliebhaber und
das sind ja praktisch alle menschen
[Musik]
er wirkt sehr sehr entspanntes kaltner
besser
[Musik]
das ist schön aber nochmal wir parken
homepage um machenschaften geheim
ich frage aber eigentlich nicht modell
hat die welle warten sind hoch sein aber
die maxime wahrscheinlich eine andere
oder ist das motto wenn das ist folglich
will aber weitermachen
ich muss den laden nicht direkt wegen
eines vaters übernehmen
aber meine eltern haben das geschäft
aufgebaut
ich fände es schade wenn es nicht
weitergehen ich möchte es weiterleben
lassen und dann meine kinder weitergeben
als familien vermächtnisse viele man
sozial und träume von anderen erzählt
mir dennis aber am schluss entscheidet
ich halt doch meistens für traditionelle
war wie viele junge hatte die mannschaft
ab der er nur der heimat seiner mutter
und der großmutter von mallorca
gestorben
[Applaus]
sie freut sich sonja war sie froh ihre
an kurve war dies ein messer zu erfahren
kann die dachterrasse moderner der oscar
ist sie stolz auf daran dass er damit
gemacht hat wo nicht sagen dass ich
wieder davis cup
[Musik]
zusammen machen würden das ist ein
traditioneller japanischer eintopf der
jugendfeuerwehr langsam dass muscheln
und krabben fischladen pulli pilz und
mehr
villis
[Musik]
wow
ich danke und dh ich nehme es auch dank
des engagements
und im inneren sprach heißt das angehört
oder angehört
[Musik]
metropolitanregion um tokio ist die
kräfte waren zwei millionen menschen
leben hier und darf oberfläche wo nur
rund ein drittel so groß ist wird
schweiz und das rammen immer mehr liegt
auf tokio
[Musik]
viele von ihnen trugen sie hoffen teigl
stars japan sei bei dem millionen moloch
tokio sind zart diesige für junge frauen
und männer so welte bedient werden
ich würde gerne himmel cholesterin
japanische pop ist und ich bekomme die
mittelfeld ich darf ein gruppe trafen
war schon bitter ist
[Musik]
carmen georges kamen djordjic übersetzt
heißt das die masken mädchen in ihrer
biografie steht mosca trage sie als
zeichen von protest gegen schönheits und
jugendwahn industrie erbringt das 2 1
vor der etablierte mitglieder
verschiedener behörden so regina k
manager kein kostüm gefällt mir sehr
hübsch und sind dass die schuhe die dazu
gehören
das bist du wie ist das für dich auf
einem magazincover zu sein ist ja okay
ich ganz deutlich es ist ein job den
tisch das so ist
wenn ich das ist die größte war für sie
hat die maske also zum beispiel visuelle
eindruck das ist ein eindruck mit einer
maske wo sehr stark ist mit der
identität aufbauen wo man wieder erkannt
dass ist war vom management okay wenn
man langsam bewegen
der fromme mann gehörte marketing-gag
protest
dann erinnert gestartet akihabara
beliebt
dass ich jetzt schon modell großen
kindern ein prominenter redner war sie
immer wieder fotografiert
das sind nicht nur sängerin sondern ein
modell für farbige der erste job hinter
ihren wagemut von virtual reality viewer
verläuft wie hat sie das erlebt
zwei kolleginnen der fall mohammadi
zusammen posieren die maske menschen in
ihrem bühne lockt
und so geht's weiter zum nächsten
auftrag
die zweite station an dem morgen ist das
so genannte kaffee an beliebte
attraktion dem quartier
heute machen wir werbefotos für diese
touristenkarte von aki habe die karte
[Musik]
mit irgendeinem fällige theorien
die in schmitten irgendwie kennt mitleid
will zieht für mitleid allerdings nicht
mit dem gummistiefeln extremes bild sie
glaube ich frage mich ob die oberfläche
ist eigentlich bewusst hinterland man
sich für eine karriere entscheidend aber
sich auch wenn ich sehe was du alles ist
ziemlich
körperlich ist es oft anstrengend aber
es gefällt mir ich habe spaß an dieser
arbeit meine motivation treibt mich an
[Musik]
ohne eine einzige pause gehts für
höhepunkt werden rostock zu oft wird auf
band immer groß events auf
ein lohn gibt es nur für die alte
ständig ihre 20 sind und das ist nicht
viel
zwei frauen kann im monat panisch und
horst und lucy punch es war nämlich im
haus vom management
zeit für das privatleben bleibt an ihrer
seite haben verschiedene die frage sie
legt zwar fröhlich drein aber irgendwie
kann ich trotzdem ist komisches gefühl
leverkusens management ich muss ich mir
das vorstellen
[Musik]
ja so ist es
wir übernehmen die verantwortung für die
erziehung anstelle der eltern nicht alle
arbeiten jeden tag die neunjährige nur
einmal pro woche arena ist momentan sehr
viel beschäftigt und arbeitet täglich
wir helfen ja auch wenn sie zum beispiel
zeit braucht für eine massage oder zeit
zum essen
erinner hatte eine augenkrankheit und
wir haben einen guten arzt für sie
gemacht
wir kümmern uns gut um unsere mädchen
und trotzdem habe ich irgendwie typische
wagen im business behandelt wie ein
einziges versöhnt der stimmige kulisse
die spitzenklasse lager und das hat ja
irgendwie einer bis völlig
[Musik]
sind dass mancher oder mobbing
[Applaus]
stimmen aufstellt richtige weg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im vorwiegend man publikum sind fertige
frage im oman schwarzeneggers wenn sich
jetzt einfach locker
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mir bringt oktober sind ferien
ich hatte sich nach jeder und die letzte
nacht nur sehr wenig schlafe ich bin
froh endlich zuvor beschlossen
nach der ersten woche storyboard tag
aufs land fahren im quelle vom bahnhof
china weiter gewachsen
das ist der japanische
hochgeschwindigkeitszug wovon ein
gitternetz bis zu 320 stundenkilometer
schnell fort
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von mächtige machen uns mit die
heimische band donots und druckvoll mit
lokaler spezialitäten auf japanisch märz
und und vertieft
[Musik]
das sind kann wenn dieser runde zu
rasante meter claudia was verzeichnet
ist er zum std und oft sekunde knapp
zucker wieder ab präzise gates mit
da sind wir nicht durch irgendeine reise
und dieser fakt ist alles sehr viel aber
manchmal das asylrecht und drehmaschinen
kreis esslingen mit der hupe wischer
entspanne ich mich
ich stelle zurück und intensive tag und
nacht tokio und die mannschaft ak
entleert und fotografiert haben
parker kristin die japanische fernseh
star diego wo zwei jobs macht zum handel
aber
[Musik]
um carmen schomann betrugen horizont
tokio seoul mit in zukunft teurer im
westen vor
jetzt im autowrack sitzball feiner kerl
gebildet und im links lehrer
hast du mir linke sieht das sind die
dinge die auf der linken sowie sie look
des spiegels verschoben
okay ist kräftig und demi moore
[Musik]
wir übernachten ein privates von der
gastfamilie mein job im begriff sentiert
übernachtet macht uns morgen bed and
breakfast of japan ist sozusagen eine
traditionelle hitze zu schlafen aber
foto offenbar mit der dame motto ist
kritisch hendry schrank versteckt sich
eine sehr aufwändige buddhistische
schreien nordhues auf der webseite
meister japanischer hilfe gibt
plötzlich streckten kopf dass er sich
hier in miami yamazaki ich sage ihm mit
klischees und erklärt mit ein paar
eingeleitet
sollte eigentlich holz wieder gutmachen
alles aus holz und kein einziger nicht
ein
und das hat zu sorgen wunderschön
claudia d okay das ist nicht stossend
dass ich von einem baum wo kein landwirt
dass janukowitsch das wird der ruf kleid
geschichte des kürzt real 10
dachisolierung hervorragend sie haben
schnell ab und sind wasserdicht
also schraubt seine kölner einheitlich
gibt für die japanische nicht nicht
einmal die berge aber traute mir sondern
auch trotzdem nicht zum 14 14 8 nimmt
maria sagte sokol und laserdom behälter
[Musik]
die traditionelle japanische werk
flasche gibt es die ganze nacht
wunderbar warm
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen schnitts angehörte
klarheit für die eine von der heiße
quellen zuordnen und seien viele
japanerinnen und japaner kagawa
scheinbar die rituale und dann da musste
ich nie auch noch in schweden bereits
infiziert mit yakuza also mit der
japanischen mafia dass nur die böse
stiefmutter
ich wage es zum glück hat es am morgen
eine zufällig im online-special form
baut ist sehr wichtig dabei werden oder
körper sondern auch den geist gereinigt
erst einmal ganz übergeben
das schönste tor
herrlich wie ein sportler
wer sie berät fortsetzung zum abend ihr
in den nächsten dreißig größten stadt
onagawa im nordosten von land staat wird
nach aufgebot
seit die genfer die zunahme ist komplett
zerstört
matthew barneys arbeitslos und sehr
effizient vor
wie war das ist gar nicht gut aber ich
bin am ende meiner shinkansen putzt wird
und ich traf eine starke frau
jörg okamoto zeigt mir das aikido nicht
nur sport sondern erhalten philosophisch
[Musik]
focus japan mit globetrotter am
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte die
reise bald wie globetrotter punkt ch